l'hôtellerie l'automobile la
restauration ou encore l'aéronautique
rares sont les secteurs aujourd'hui qui
ne pâtissent pas de la crise la gare le
département de statistique du ministère
du travail recense aujourd'hui 275 plan
de sauvegarde de l'emploi
entre le 1er mars dernier et le 19
juillet dernier
au total 43 1343 postes sont concernés
par exemple chez air france la direction
a annoncé début juillet un plan social
résultat 7580 postes soit 16% des
effectifs sont aujourd'hui menacés
interrogée et quelques jours après cette
annonce bruno le maire le ministre de
l'économie et des finances et de la
relance estimé à demi mot qu'un plan
social était inévitable quand les
commandes s'écroule quand le trafic
aérien s'écroule dire voilà je mets de
l'argent mais on veut absolument garder
chaque emploi ça peut conduire à des
risques de faillite et au bout du compte
à perdre tout l'argent des français
ces 7 milliards sont l'argent des
français si demain air france fait
faillite c'est 7 milliards qui partent
en fumée et dont je suis responsable et
depuis le mois de juillet dernier les
entreprises sont toujours plus
nombreuses a annoncé des plans sociaux
parmi elles lagence de voyages twin à
flasher à l'ina ou encore engrais bon
nombre de ces entreprises étaient déjà
mal en point
le coc vie 19 leur a porté le coup de
grâce
alors pour tenter d'endiguer cette vague
de licenciements
le gouvernement essaye plusieurs leviers
à commencer par le prêt garanti par
l'état accordé à plus de 500 milles
entreprises pour un total de 100
milliards d'euros avec pour condition le
non versement de dividendes aux
actionnaires
un coup de pouce aux entreprises qui au
final ne semble pas être suffisant en
début de semaine ses camaïeux l'enseigne
de prêt-à-porter qui annonçait à son
tour un plan social
si certaines entreprises sont rudement
touchée par la crise et se doivent de
remercier leurs employés d'autres sont
accusés par les syndicats de profiter de
cette crise pour licencier
il y a les entreprises qui souffrent à
cause du coût
vides il y à des entreprises qui
utilisent d'une certaine manière cette
période là pour organiser des plans
sociaux inacceptable c'est le cas de
nokia
l'entreprise s'était engagé à maintenir
l'emploi jusqu'en juin 2020 elle
annoncée au 1er juin qu'elle ne
garderait pas les jeunes ingénieurs
qu'elle avait embauché
c'est inacceptable et avec
l'augmentation du nombre de cas de
covile 19 en france à les entreprises
voient aujourd'hui une nouvelle crainte
surgir la crainte justement d'un
deuxième confinement une décision qui
serait forcément à dramatique pour les
emplois et le tissu économique français
[Applaudissements]